we're going deep hey everyone i'm abby
sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by billbar
and i want to share my thoughts on will
smith's youtube documentary best shape
of my life but first let me tell you
about my sponsor billbar it is snack
o'clock around here and i am excited for
today's belt bar snack pardon my
terrible french i'm a bad canadian let's
bust into this bad boy what are we
feeling like today
i'm digging i'm digging i'm digging
i see my favorite back here
cookies and cream
she is good
feeling like a cookie
the song that's my head i'm gonna make
my editor guess just kidding i'll tell
you get it get it get it is that a song
that's the forbidden dance mmm
i'm into this these are my favorite
protein bars really the only bar i like
because i like bars that taste like
chocolate bars not chalk that's key key
distinction but these ones are packed
with protein so bonus now so my favorite
ways to eat a build bar include on
oatmeal so good yogurt a little ice
cream straight up naked
the bars obviously not me though no
shade if that's your thing but if you
want to give these bars a try check out
my promo code abbiesharp15 to get 15
off of your order okay and a quick
disclaimer and trigger warning that this
series deals with not only dieting but
also themes related to domestic and
childhood abuse so definitely do not
watch if that's not supportive to your
journey and if you're not already
subscribed hit that subscribe button hit
the little dingy dingy ding bell so that
you don't miss out and follow me over on
tick tock and instagram abby's kitchen
all right to set the stage here will
smith started a youtube documentary in
november to document writing his memoir
and his goal to lose 20 pounds in 20
weeks so today i'm going to be
discussing some of my key takeaways from
the series as it relates to will's
weight loss goal first of all i want to
discuss one of the major cautionary
tales of this series which is that the
scale can actually be a dangerous tool
for some particularly for goal oriented
people now throughout the series we see
will getting on the scale regularly and
sometimes the number isn't what he wants
to see like so many people he expects to
see linear weight loss every week to
meet his 20 pound in 20 week goal but as
will's journey demonstrates nothing
about weight loss is straightforward or
simple the challenge is that will is
highly goal oriented he sees what he
wants then he goes out and gets it but
weight is not necessarily something that
we can precisely control and what
happens when someone who is highly
motivated by meeting their goals doesn't
actually meet them or as will's
psychologist puts it how the heck does
this guy cope
when he's not winning well it's not only
frustrating but it can actually trigger
some potentially destructive behaviors
when he doesn't lose his nice round
weekly pound i've been doing this stupid
crap and
i don't care what i weigh are you
feeling this morning well low energy did
you react to it in terms of the amount
of food that you ate this week i had two
days worth of reaction boiled eggs raw
vegetables that's it and i was doing
like 14 hours of fast
yeah
so this week is going to be ridiculous
wake up weigh in run right down then i'm
into the bag my first workout and a
second workout do a finisher just to
blow it out i've been doing the writing
session it's 4 27 i am going running
and then going to shoot things training
i only got four hours and 28 minutes of
sleep
will is motivated as
and goal-oriented people like this will
fight as long as they possibly can to
get where they want to be but even
motivated people lose their drive when
their source of validation which in
will's case is the scale becomes
invalidating and as his psychologist
says the more a person is stretched
sooner or later they snap
yep they snap they burn out they get
injured as he did at one point in the
journey or they just throw in the towel
and completely quit i don't want to do
any of this
i'm finished with
uh this project in my mind we blew it
we missed it it's over
and we got to stop and i'm ready to stop
giving up on a goal is usually what
happens when the goal is not entirely
within our control which as you can
imagine is a tough loss for us
goal-oriented people and in this case
where will's body weight chooses to land
and at what pace is not something that
he has direct control over regardless of
his commitment to his diet and fitness
plan and this brings me to my next big
takeaway message here which is that
perfectionist all or nothing thinking is
often our worst enemy when it comes to
changing hard habits i have to admit
that watching this series was both
triggering and therapeutic to me because
personally i saw a lot of myself in will
i have struggled with perfectionist
tendencies my whole life and like will i
feel like this has contributed to some
of my successes but also created major
barriers to life success because it's
created an anxiety that has at times
prevented me from taking risks what i
see and will is a relentless drive to go
all in and to run to the top of the hill
with that [ __ ] flag no matter what
and while this mentality is admirable in
some cases and is undoubtedly an asset
to his career success it isn't without
sacrifice now from listening to will's
own storytelling in this series it's
apparent that this all or nothing
mentality began at a very young age i
was on a tear the biggest winning streak
in hollywood history i noticed that most
people came back from christmas vacation
heavier and out of shape so the holidays
for me became an opportunity to extend
my lead i made it a point to come back
every new year in better shape than i
left last i would work out and sometimes
even abstain from christmas dinner as an
act of personal discipline so these all
or nothing tendencies particularly when
it comes to food are possibly innate and
may be a result of his challenging
relationship with his dad which he
actually alludes to himself his father
seemed to put a lot of pressure on him
and it seemed like he felt a big
responsibility to do him right and we
see throughout the series that he will
often push himself so hard and so far
and actually shame himself for anything
less than excellence but in the end this
is actually what maybe holds him back i
was looking at the building
and it dawned on me
that we hadn't actually climbed to the
top of the burj khalifa and my sense of
accomplishment
turned into a dejected sense of failure
it might sound strange coming from a
trainer but you really have to keep a
close eye on him in terms of pushing too
hard he'll just keep going until he he
dies uh or gets injured well i can't run
in the morning and i talked all that
crap
so in will's case climbing 160 stories
wasn't enough he had to literally go to
the tip top toe of that building
whatever a tip-top toe is but same with
meeting his step goal like he had to
literally run the equivalent of a
marathon every day to feel that he did
enough and the result was that he
actually injured himself which lost him
the step challenge in the end trivial
maybe but i would say symbolic
nonetheless now i say goals are great i
am a strong believer in goals and like i
said i too am a very goal oriented
person but when reaching and exceeding
the goal becomes an obsession that
ultimately jeopardizes the end goal of
better health and happiness it's really
a slippery slope and i know this
personally because i've experienced the
cost of striving for absolute perfection
i mean i would say his therapist said it
best and this is such a danger to people
who start succeeding especially when
they start succeeding young
you've set yourself up that you have to
keep winning now i am not diagnosing
anything specific to will i actually
think he seems to be doing a really
great job acknowledging his own triggers
and emotional limitations but it's worth
noting that perfectionist traits are
more common in folks with eating
disorders or disordered eating compared
to the general population so this is one
reason why i think extreme diet
challenges like these do require a real
risk benefit analysis here's what i've
learned about perfectionism it can often
keep you locked in a rigid mindset and a
behavior pattern that maybe doesn't
actually serve you very well in the long
run you spend so much time trying to be
perfect that it kills authenticity and
leaves no room for development growth or
even failure and will himself has
previously said that failure is
essential for success so it sounds like
he's taking a page out of his own book
by reframing his goal and focusing
instead on authenticity
because i can do anything
when i you know
tap into that soldier
right so it's not about the
yeah harsh energy it's hard yeah a more
sustainable mindset when i was in
university and beating myself up over
getting an a minus over an a plus one of
the most impactful things that my father
who was a professor ever said to me
about my perfectionism was abby if you
put yourself on a pedestal like this
you'll have nowhere left to grow and
he's totally right so i feel like will
is starting to realize that
perfectionism is no longer necessarily a
strength because in reality it sometimes
reduces life down to a very boring
series of emotions with very little
purpose or pleasure so ultimately what
is my advice
i say the goal here needs to change
if will was my client i would probably
tell him to put the weight loss
challenge on the back burner i don't
think it's actually helping him write
the book and i also don't think it's
going to net out any positive health
outcome either my focus instead would be
twofold one to focus on giving himself
some mental space for healing as he
unearths potentially painful memories
the weight gain or weight loss right now
is such a distraction from everything
else going on it's just so not about the
food and from what i can see i also
think he kind of knows this 202
flat
would be on schedule
your expert opinion mr ferguson does
that have anything to do with my age
or more to do with my food selection
i think it's got a little bit to do with
your brain it's not about the weight
or
the book
as much as what it says about my mind my
mind is suffering and subject to the
same appetites and desires and cravings
and self-destructive behavior as
everybody else and his team also seems
to know that putting the weight loss on
the back burner is in his best interest
as well even if at face value it may be
read as like a cop out or a failure will
quitting the show
may look like a failure to a lot of
people but there's actually another way
to look at it as
a breakthrough will is choosing himself
he's not hiding behind humor or control
or the idea of winning instead he's
giving himself space to process and deal
with his past someone's taking a step
back and not performing not producing
not succeeding in the conventional sense
is the best evidence of life progress so
my second suggestion on this is that
when and if will does decide to revisit
the food and exercise piece i would
recommend shifting the focus from any
kind of end goal towards the process in
other words rather than being goal
oriented to shift to being process
oriented and i think will actually comes
to this realization himself when he
realized that the structure of this kind
of high production weight loss series
isn't actually serving him it's not
helping his mental health it's not
helping his physical health and it's not
even helping him reach the weight goal
like don't
tell me about the schedule i don't want
the show or something like that mindset
is disruptive to me in the creative
process further to that he comes to
realize that the weight loss goal or
book writing goal isn't actually helpful
at all and the process and what he
learns from it is actually the most
valuable piece sometimes achieving the
actual goal earns you almost nothing but
the journey itself
teaches you everything you need to know
being process oriented towards this
weight loss journey is similar to
applying the intuitive eating concept of
data collection losing 20 pounds
instantly wouldn't really teach us
anything about nutrition or our bodies
if it was just to happen to us but if we
were to focus on the process we would
have a lot more motivation to maintain
the behaviors that serve us and to let
go of those that don't
so asking ourselves questions like how
does cutting 500 calories make us feel
how do we feel after our second workout
of the day do we binge on the weekends
are we cranky all the time is our sleep
affected do we feel energized how's our
digestion can we eat like this forever
or are we just going to crash binge or
become very unhappy people this is the
introspective information that really
helps shape our behaviors with better
awareness in the long term i also think
that when we set numeric weight loss
goals like 20 pounds and 20 weeks that
we lose sight of the forest from the
trees or in a metaphor used by will
himself we get lost worrying about the
wall
rather than each individual brick in the
series will talks about how his father
made his brother in him build a wall as
a project and he always used to feel so
defeated looking at this huge wall that
he needed to build but his father would
say forget about the wall worry about
that one brick it's the same thing with
weight loss the wall is the weight loss
goal and often it can become really
distracting when we see this big gaping
hole that we know we need to fill and we
don't know where to start
start with what you can manage every day
start with what you can actually control
what can we accomplish that we have
control over so that could mean i'm
gonna work out three days this week or
i'm gonna have salad with my lunch four
days this week let's just focus on that
goal and when we meet it we reevaluate
it to continue or add on i think the
will smith series actually paints a
pretty authentic and nuanced look at the
intersection of one's relationship with
food and body and everything else going
on in their life and also it
specifically highlights the role of
perfectionism in weight loss journeys
i'm really glad that will has a skilled
team here who genuinely seems to have
his best interest at heart but i also
know that most people looking to lose
weight do not have those same supports
this can and often is a slippery slope i
know because i was there and it resulted
in a pretty severe ed so i acknowledge
that for a lot of you weight loss is
very much desired but this is just my
reminder to really know your triggers
weigh out the benefits and risks of
dieting and to focus on more gentle
nutrition if dieting is not supportive
for you and if this is not triggering
please check out my video on gentle
nutrition tips for weight loss which you
can see right here and on that note that
is all that i have for you guys today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on your thoughts on the will smith
documentary thank you again to billbar
for sponsoring subscribe and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]